durante la semana este centro cultural
ruso ha sufrido varios actos de
vandalismo en esta oportunidad el
director llamó a la policía para
denunciar que entrada del edificio
amaneció pintada de color rojo es
imposible no notar una verdadera
histeria antes
desde el comienzo de la guerra en
ucrania los miembros de la comunidad
rusa en parís también denuncian insultos
como este estudiante que prefirió
permanecer en el anonimato
sans con seis fui a un médico francés le
di mi tarjeta sanitaria y vio que era
rusa y me preguntó estás contenta con lo
que ha hecho tu presidente que está en
crisis aún así en su librería natalia
touring ha optado por mostrar en su
escaparate su solidaridad con el pueblo
ucraniano y los libros sobre ucrania
ocupan un lugar destacado
vidal
los que tienen poco corazón por supuesto
viven mal después el problema es que no
son más desgraciados que los que están
bajo las bombas y siguen estando mucho
mejor que los que están en moscú que se
arriesgan a 15 años de cárcel por decir
lo que no deben así que a los rusos de
parís no hay que compadecer los
la vigilancia se ha intensificado en
ciertos lugares frecuentados por la
comunidad rusa como la catedral de santa
trinidad o el conservatorio rakhmàninov
cuyos visitantes denuncian haber
recibido amenazas de muerte